liebe ist ein bisschen als mr
zwischen lecker
[Musik]
hallo zusammen willkommen bei mir im
kopf wie kaum eine andere perspektive
wir machen heute top 3 starbucks rezepte
also getränke einfach die die ich am
leckersten finde und die die ihr auch
feiert also ich fange jetzt direkt mit
dem ersten anders ist jetzt glaube ich
ihm auf der karte wie nennt sich das
eine branche ach so ich viele wörter wie
blenden es hier ein obwohl hp stellt vor
sehr lecker so dafür nimmt muss
natürlich braunen zucker ich glaube dass
hier in so einem gefäß da waren mal ich
weiß nicht kirchen oder so drin und der
zug kommt jetzt noch vanille extrakt
könnte auch bei den sirup nehme ich
glaube über starbucks aber extrakt das
ist einfach natürlicher intensiver so
und da brauchen wir jetzt einen schönen
espresso bin mache ich mir jetzt grad
also einmal sie träger immer siebträger
ich glaube alle die auch eine sie träger
maschine haben die verstehen mich das
ist halt wirklich so man fühlt sich so
ein barista und da wir auch bald ein
coffee to go konzept haben als direkt
vor unserem start habe ich auch in
vergangenheit extrem viele varianten
ausprobiert das heißt ihr könnt nicht
bald barista kiki nennen ich bin hier
nur am kaffee varianten ausprobieren so
und es brühe ich jetzt man dann kommt
das gleich mit ins rathaus und dann wird
ordentlich geschüttelt
[Musik]
zusätzlich hier richtig schön schaum
gebildet und wir fangen jetzt aber erst
mit dem eis an das sind nämlich ein
kaltes getränk
also schön kross einmal eingeben
eventuell haben wir uns dieses diesem
starbucks becher vor dem dreh noch extra
besorgt diese weise liebe so und dann
einmal den chance dazu dann wird
eigentlich auch mit milch aufgefüllt
[Musik]
so ein bisschen als mr
wer dieses geräusch das man wird also
was soll ich sagen ich weiß dass es
schmecken wird aber ich probiere für
euch lecker richtig lecker genau meine
süße mit dem braunen zucker und dem man
den extra kiss genau perfekt die milch
gibt ja auch noch einiges und süße ab
stärke des kaffees optimal hat mit
einfachen espresso rainer und wer ist
stärker mag einen doppelten espresso
mieses dann immer ein bisschen zu stark
auf jeden fall blieb ich könnte mir dass
es noch in aller ruhe und dann geht es
über zum nächsten rezept soll der
pinguin war letztes jahr so geheilt ist
ja aber immer noch und ich finde die
kann man sich im sommer eigentlich auch
immer gönnen das ist nichts mit koffein
also heute also jetzt mal eine große
freie variante allgemein lieblichkeit
getränk mit koffein ich habe jetzt die
eiswürfel digital fans die die habe ich
verkauft dann entdeckt dass und so runde
kügelchen hatte auch mal runter also für
mega damit könnt ihr euch die auch
selber machen die eiswürfel jetzt auch
nicht zuvor machen wir müssen mehr
gleich noch unsere tiefgekühlten früchte
oben drauf packen aber jetzt kommt
erstmal hibiskus stets im einsatz ich
habe die idee bis kosten aus meinem shop
genommen spätestens seit der hibiskus
blüten torte wird direkt ein absoluter
fan schmeckt so frisch und lecker es
gebe ich jetzt einmal hier rein was auch
nicht fehlen da selbst einmal
holunderblütensirup auch ganz typisch
gebe ich direkt mit dazu das vermischt
sich auch ganz von alleine aus dem
trinkt man doch sowieso mit einem
strohhalm das heißt man kann immer
wieder rühren also ich muss sagen ich
habe nach armeeangaben in infobox aber
das ist er so nach gefühl hier die
tiefgekühlten früchte jetzt wäre das
ganze jahr über im tiefkühlregal wenn
ihr frische früchte neben möchtet müsst
ihr aber vorher auch ein trainer so tut
sich da nicht viel da habe ich jetzt
heidelbeeren himbeeren und erdbeeren
genommen so und jetzt kommt der schönen
moment jetzt kommt noch milch eurer wahl
dazu viele nehmen kokosmilch ich ihnen
heute ganz normale milch ihr könnt auch
hafer oder soja nehmen
langsam sondern ist es eigentlich auch
schon fertig und ihr könnt euch sofort
schmecken lassen
[Musik]
ich habe gerade jetzt nochmal die
gleiche variante jedoch mit kokosmilch
ausprobiert weil das ganze typisch ist
mit kokosmilch und ich muss sagen das
sieht auch ästhetische aus für immer ein
bisschen natürlich probieren kann ja
sehr erfrischend auch nicht zu süß muss
ich sagen was überhaupt nicht zu süß ist
es ganz all diejenigen die sie mögen
wenn ich sie verrückt macht mehr sinn
oder vision zero breiten wir angerannt
diskus diskus und holunderblüte versand
und die früchte kann man dann später
mache
ja aber die ihr kann man diese halbieren
können aber am ende ich mag das wenn
nichts mehr drin und der rest kommt dann
noch so ein
kaufmann dann ist das okay das nicht so
angepasst den euro teil ja genau das war
der grund dass wegen
der aist caramel macchiato ist ein
getränk das ich jeder tageszeit trinken
kann das schmeckt mir persönlich themas
1 tura klassiker und ich trinke das auch
sowohl im sommer als auch im winter wir
nehmen uns dafür karamellsoße also den
karamellsoße war ich nehme meine tree
lecce soße und gibt da jetzt erst mal
auf dem boden ein bisschen was gleich
kommt auch noch an den rand ein bisschen
was von der karamell vanille extrakt ihr
könnt auch vanille sirup nehmen das
extrakt schmeckt super intensiv daher
nehme ich das und da habe ich halt immer
da
und dann könnt ihr mit eurem strom
energie verwendet die beiden zutaten
einfach ein bisschen mit einem apéro
anschließend können wir dann quasi
richtig schön den rand mit der
karamellsoße decken auch nicht so geizig
sein
ganz wie eiswürfel will ich jetzt mit
paul und spritze habe ich mir schon
gebrüht ihr könnt den espresso auch
direkt heinz mit rein und es gibt
sowieso direkt abbringen eislöffel
meiner ist zum abgekühlt daher
ist es sowieso schon kalt aber wie
gesagt keine steuer sitzt wenn ihr den
komplex gebrütet könnt ihr einfach mit
dazu tun also gebe jetzt mal ein
espresso schott hier rein und
dann kommt einfach nur noch milch eurer
wahl und top und dann habe ich mir noch
ein bisschen sahne aufgeschlagen ich
habe frische genommen wir können auch
sprühsahne nehmen und oder gebe ich noch
ein bisschen was in der kasse das war's
[Applaus]
[Musik]
so ich probiere mal als lustig wie es
schmeckt aber ich liebe es einfach
[Musik]
geil leute einfach lecker steht schnell
man hat eigentlich immer alles da
religious ist der hammer wandel kommt
raus am ende verrückt dann halt noch ein
bisschen und doch soll ich sagen ich
liebe ich liebe es einfach macht
unbedingt nach so das waren meine top
preis da wachs getränke wobei ich ganz
viel mehr habe also wenn ihr noch
weitere starbucks getränke von mir sehen
möchtet schreibt man eure top favoriten
jetzt in die kommentare dann kann ich
noch ein paar zwei davon machen und
ansonsten viel spaß beim ausprobieren
leute könnt euch und abonniert mein karl
kostenlos wenn ich nicht schon längst
getan habt also bis dann
[Musik]
[Applaus]